there's a fox news alert today a
horrific
explosion rocking beirut lebanon killing
dozens of people injuring thousands
here live from the region with the very
latest mabel khalid is with us mabel
good evening it's definitely a sad night
for the lebanese people tonight
a disaster in every sense of the word
the explosion caused widespread damage
to buildings in different parts of the
city
as a first statement for mr muhammad
family lebanon's interior minister
said it was apparently caused by
ammonium nitrate that was stored in our
warehouse and at the port in beirut
health minister hamad hassan stated at
least 78 have been killed
and more than 4 000 are wounded there
are many people missing until now
people are asking the emergency
department about their loved ones
and it's difficult to search at night
because there is no electricity
we are facing a real catastrophe and
beirut hospitals tonight are overwhelmed
with the injury
red cross is called for all its
ambulances all over
to come to wait and help
all right mabel thank you i mean what
you're saying is we've got a breaking up
there
um we're talking about ammonia nitrate
that's what happened
wow and 4 000 injuries she was reporting
okay